yeah i think that there
are basic things that if i may everyone
should do in order to anchor their body
and their mind in the most productive
rhythm that they possibly can the the
most important things are the
foundational practices which are get
your sleep right best way to get your
sleep right is get your morning sunlight
exposure
ideally within an hour of waking up
again if you wake up before the sun
comes out flip on as many lights as you
possibly can
if you want to be awake that's one one
basic way to just set the whole thing in
motion properly i think everyone should
have a real-time tool for dealing with
stress the physiological size the best
one that i'm aware of which is a very
deep breath sometimes followed by
another short inhale so
and then a long exhale and the double
deep breath with a very deep breath
reinflates the little sacks in the lungs
your lungs aren't just too big bags of
air they actually have hundreds of
millions of little sacks that we call
the avioli of the lungs i think that
people should also have a way of
increasing their stress threshold and
you know there's a lot made nowadays of
of ice spas and cold showers for
dopamine release and there is evidence
for that believe it or not extended
dopamine release uh from cold showers or
or ice baths or just cold immersion
that can be very useful i also think
it's just very useful to have some sort
of breathing practice or cold water
exposure practice that you do maybe
three to seven times a week depending on
how aggressive you are to raise your
stress threshold so that you can manage
under conditions of high adrenaline so
have a real-time tool have a tool to
increase resilience or stress tolerance
then also try and limit your light
exposure in the evening
try and dim those lights bring them low
in the environment try and make the room
cool so you can sleep well pile on the
blankets if you want that doesn't mean
being cold it means having your
environment be cold so you can toss off
the blankets as needed and get deep
sleep the other things i think can be
very useful is to think about this
three-phase
view of states both in sleep and awake
that you know from zero to eight or nine
hours after waking that's going to be
high energy high output uh high
adrenaline uh just naturally high
cortisol so linear type of operations
that people always say you know what's
your morning routine do you do the most
difficult thing early in the day not
necessarily sometimes i do the most
boring um a terrible thing in the day
which for me would be like an excel
spreadsheet for me is just i'd rather
get hives than do an excel spreadsheet
but the most difficult thing might be
the creative work which would fall or
brainstorming work or where it's what we
would call non-linear type thing taking
existing elements but arranging them in
new ways uh probably best done for most
people in the second phase of the day
and then of course from 17 to 24 hours
after waking you want to be asleep
naps and deep rest are terrific limit
them to 90 minutes or less and don't do
them at all if they inhibit your ability
to sleep at night
[Music]
so
[Music]
you